on va tout jouer vasic ce qui t'arrive
tu dois rien je te comptes tu me cote
comme ça ça va partir je te dis ça par
la petite phase i/iia tant que nous
mettons macao bien mon chéri c'est très
c'est très important pour toi je
t'explique tu vas voir quatre
combattants qui vont être face à toi ils
m'ont cru et ils l'ont très mal mais le
truc très belle tu voir quatre
combattants qui va de façade qui monte
face à toi tu rares moi d'abord mais moi
s pour t'entraîner il est pas allé par
sa gueule alors tout de suite
pascal le grand frère que tu vas devoir
également affronter et il y aura un
troisième combattant très très bas
l'aise si tu bats les trois combattants
au sumo c'est à dire si tu arrive à nous
faire sortir du cercle tu partiras et je
te jure que c'est vrai à macao avec la
personne de son choix avec qui tu
appartiens à carreaux avec qui tu vas
partir à macao chose
tassos as-tu paraît qu'une chose ce
tartare de sketchup sauce moutarde sign
of time of time of art est de pousser
comme ça ça va partir et que je te le
dis tu fais gaffe il est sympa le
président pas super sympa bien parce
qu'elle était garde du corps de deux des
manuels mâcon franchement dans cerenis
un pas politiquement par voir je vais
pas en parler mais honnêtement parlant
c'est vrai qu'il ya rien à dire ils ont
salle carnot a donc tu lecture à vue
brigitte et emmanuel où il va faire un
petit coucou l'a pas dit gros bisous
chef mobile gros mise à la première dame
résidant à toi tu me vois comme ça tu
dis c'est moi que tu aurais dû prendre à
vrai dire l'oeuf moi si on arrêtait
direct comme s'abîme pascal tu vas
affronter macao dans un instant d'abord
on va ça fait mal thwala vas-y fais pas
le malin je fais pas le malin
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et pas vrai alors je vais dire j'ai fait
ça parce que je veux qu'il parte à macao
des fonds se défonce le sas à mon tour
ouais alors on est très très vite
regardez bien ça va être sympa
ça fonctionne bien c'est bon ça va aller
très très vite sa a vendu quelques
minutes quand tu parles et de
non-violence août alors d'accord
rassurer
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
avant
voilà en fait quelqu'un qui est là pour
toi je savais que j'allais me direz à
toi mais je vais m je suis le mec le
plus intelligent par rapport à toi je
suis pas sur la force sur le l'esprit
donc mais au fait il va se mettre à ma
place
en quelques secondes on exactement
[Musique]
toile et beiteinou avait pas de violence
dans l'esprit
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
tha
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
vannes oc sécurité notre dame pour
attention youssef qui s'occupait là tu
préfères
conforme à celui merdé vous bien deux
extrémités l'échec si macao
je ne rigole pas facal arrive à battre
nous 7 il partira à macao en séjour et
sachez qu y aura quelqu'un aussi qu'ils
sachent les recruteurs qui partira à
macao également attaché à ce que vous
n'êtes pas les gars 3 2
[Applaudissements]
sur le ralenti c'est nous c'est à ce
qu'ils sortent au premier sens
non non je suis satisfait macairois
gagner voilà c'est une fièvre qui sort
en premier le pied sans en premier le
pied youssef et macao
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ouais
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
non même pas masos takoucht q la haye la
native fait attendre
[Musique]
et là une autre personne qui partira
jeudi à macao les chéris avant de faire
les quatre tirs de jean luc lemoine a
été a été formidable les contents mais
tu pas vraiment à macao frère